neulich haben wir getrocknete pflaumen
von der 4 x 1
da nicht so wird sie wieder etwas klappt
und herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch
geht's gut ich weiß nicht ob alles an
lausanne sid aber wahrscheinlich schon
und der winkel ist jetzt auch oder ihr
seht mich ein bisschen kleiner sonst war
immer so ist auch nur sehr kleine kamera
ich habe meinen blog kann zugelegt aber
ich kann ja sogar den bildschirm um klar
fällt mir dort auf ja ist wirklich sehr
entspannt und damit mache ich jetzt
meine videos hier auf dem hauptkanal man
kann hier auf jeden fall einiges an
qualität rausholen wenn jetzt noch nicht
so gut ist seid ihr nicht böse ich muss
mich haben wir noch mal ein bisschen
genauer beschäftigen aber das kriegen
wir auf jeden fall hin trotzdem wollte
jetzt den block auf jeden fall mit der
keb film und zwar kam mir letztens das
video von mir 24 stunden rote produkte
und ich hab ich gesagt schreib doch mal
bitte in die kommentare
auf welche fabia ist nächstes bock hat
etwas vom ausprobieren kann nochmals zur
erklärung an alle wieso ich solche
videos mache weil eigentlich ist ja auch
ein bisschen dumm dass man ja ich würde
das ding ist einfach ich mache ja in
letzter zeit öfter so essens videos und
man probiert einfach in diesen 24 jahren
so viele verschiedene sachen aus die man
sonst niemals ausprobieren würde
deswegen ist auch heute wieder eure
aufgabe schreibt eure lieblingsfarbe
oder die paarungen der wir sind als
nächstes machen sollte in die kommentare
und wir fahren jetzt los und kaufen ein
und so kam es auch mit ok korrekt möchte
die qualität ist wirklich neues also ich
bin jetzt echt weit weg von marie und
man kann auch ein problem heran suchen
leute falls solche interessiert so sieht
das aus relativ kleine kamera canon g7
mix markt zwar ist das geiles ding
glaube ich unsere weiblichen mitmenschen
muss man immer so lange warten ist
unglaublich
ich bin gleich schon erfroren hier im
auto ja hier habe ich gerade irgendetwas
gesagt ich weiß nicht mehr genau was war
ich habe das mikrofon zugehalten ich
wusste gar nicht dass das oben drauf ist
bei dieser kamera auf jeden fall ging es
glaube ich darum dass wir uns darauf
abgestimmt haben was auch produkte
reichen die blaue akzente haben weil wir
wirklich schon extrem lange nach blauen
produkten gesucht haben diese aber
leider nicht wirklich gefunden haben
weiter geht sollte man muss sagen
irgendwie blau ist extrem schwierig so
rot grün alles kein problem das ist
nicht blau also man muss sagen dass man
mit den blauen akzenten weil es sonst
halt wirklich extrem schwierig ist die
mitglieder auch nein aber da sind ja
blaue akzente so weißt du den ball rein
leute ich hoffe das versteht ihr das
nicht immer komplett blau ist aber das
geht nicht
schreibt mir blaue lebens wird in die
kommentare dann hätte ich es gemacht
aber es gibt einfach verändert einige
blaue eier wir sind aber ziemlich früh
dran mit ostern geil jawohl dankeschön
du bist die leute wenn man so
entschieden wir nehmen den anstatt hier
blau ja zum frühstück oder machen wir
dann leute ich sowas ganz bestimmt ist
und zwar das ist aber ganz schön teuer
wird mich verarschen
das war ungesund fahren was mitnehmen
okay leute hinzugekommen ist noch dieser
traubensaft und diese getrockneten
pflaumen wobei ich dir jetzt nicht so
als blaue einstufe sondern eher als lila
oder ist er nicht wir machen 50
was das
also das hat mich jetzt ja richtig ab
hier gibt's parade aber nur rot weiß
gefunden den trink ich morgen zum
frühstück
was ist das denn ist das 1 3 konnte
marie bezahlt doch eben über zum
getränkemarkt und schauen ob da noch ein
kleines getränk findet weil das einzige
was ich muss sagen wir haben sich
relativ hätte ich gar nicht mehr so
unbedingt gedacht man musste haben
leider kein getränk da dachte ich das
wäre das selbstverständlich hier irgend
ein blaues getränke gibt es ein
getränkemarkt gab es auch nicht mehr
und jetzt müssen wir das morgen früh und
ich habe allerdings eben mit meiner
mutter telefoniert weil wir immer blaue
kartoffeln gegessen an die nicht wissen
dass es das gibt es jetzt wirklich und
die versuchen morgen früh zu bekommen
weil das ja ganz wichtig sonst komme ich
nicht überall im harz manfred und ich
wünsche ihnen schöne abend bis später so
leute guten morgen
es ist zeit viel zu spät ich habe gerade
schon die erste schlechte nachricht und
gehört und zwar gibt es keine blauen
kartoffeln
das heißt wir haben einen wirklich sehr
großes ernstzunehmendes problem also ich
fange gleich auf jeden fall noch in den
biomarkt hier und schauen wir was ich da
auch bekommen und jetzt mal erst mal ein
blaues frühstück wir gespannt
ja gar nicht blau so natürlich muss man
sagen brot zum beispiel gibt es nicht in
blau das ganz klar aber trotzdem
probiert jetzt zum ersten anderem leben
laut schimmelkäse bavaria blu boa klingt
schon extrem
leute ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
verlege mittlerweile das ganze eher
wieder zu melden
weil man muss sagen das getränk er ist
leader halte ich mir irgendwann denken
die haben wir zwar leicht blaue akzente
und hier haben wir auch ja ist halt lila
ich würde sagen meine streichen biomarkt
nichts gutes finden
dann nehmen wir das einfach ein lila
augen weil es ist einfach unmöglich will
ein
das kaufen das laufwerken sowas herum ja
nicht der sinn der sache vor probleme
denn so was
da wird mir schlecht von und direkt und
ist dann musst du diese heute hatte ich
muss sagen ich habe noch nie so ein käse
gegessen und heute haben wir trauern
software wird von vornherein klar
gewesen dass das nicht blau ist ich
kannte das ja in lahr welcher dann habe
ich aber nicht gekauft also das schmeckt
lecker
wir haben die heidelberger gut mit
blauem kurze erklärung an alle die so
dumm sind wie ich also es kommt auf die
region an weil manchmal heißt dass
heidelbeeren bei manchen heißt das bier
so mehr schaue ich leider nicht
irgendwie haben wir auch schon jeder
direkt eingekauft weil das gar nicht
glauben das ist was wir jetzt doch hier
haben und ich muss jetzt auf jeden fall
noch ein kommen und ich hoffe dass wir
noch was vernünftiges finden weil sonst
die challenge direkt schon ein tollhaus
und das wollen wir natürlich nicht oder
das problem ist ich bin irgendwie sehr
unzufrieden mit der art mit der ganzen
sache so ist aber auch wirklich sehr
sehr schwierig das müsst ihr verstehen
wir fahren jetzt auch unseren
biosupermarkt guck mal was wir da so
finden und da nehme ich euch natürlich
mithin ist vielleicht hätte da bin ich
einmal hier und für eine direkte rote
nuding aber auch solche alter die sind
ja krass killer oder so leute was geht
ab ich bin wieder zu hause und ich habe
wirklich richtig coole sachen gefunden
leider habe ich das schon angedeutet
wird es wird jetzt ob lila oben weil das
problem ist einfach es gibt absolut
nichts klar ist auch in diesem laden man
denkt sich so ihr könnt mir sehr gern
lebens wieder in die kommentare
schreiben
die blau sind manchmal so drüber
nachdenken fällt einem ja auch
eigentlich nicht zeigen und zwar davon
aus dass wenn man dann einen supermarkt
geht und viele sachen sieht das dann
schon was dabei ist anscheinend leider
nicht so auch die blauen kartoffeln von
denen ich gesprochen habe sind wohl eher
so lila die natur macht von sich aus
keine blauen sachen die macht nur
glieder sachen alt wir haben jetzt für
später auf jeden fall einmal nudel in
lila
dann haben wir diese chips ebenfalls und
wieder die haben wir noch so eine frucht
und moosbeere vanille riegelt den habe
ich einfach mitgenommen weil er
hoffentlich klar ist und hier noch ein
getränk in mit mal probieren wird es
auch mal eine pflaume problem war ja
komm her
leute wir machen wir christen
geschmackstest und von den sachen die
nudeln gibt es auf jeden fall welche
abend was ist denn das jetzt ist das
schon chip hat man wird sich man gar
nicht
heute sind echt gut die frauen die
kleben machte probier doch mal die
frauen hier einmal die typ ist doch
nicht schlimm da war heute der erste
geschmack von den chips ist eigentlich
ganz gut
und dann war es ein bisschen mit total
genossen grußwort weil ich haben wir
getrocknete pflaumen von der firma nein
ich mache auch mal so ein
konkurrenzunternehmen hier haben wir
nicht nein zu verfolgen die diskussion
im supermarkt du willst laufen
nein heißt er kommt der kunde gesagt
entschuldigung gibt es vielleicht
irgendwie eine spezielle neue themen wie
auch früchte herstellen und dann sagt er
ganz nah heran
also haben wir auf jeden fall schon mal
eine richtig dicke gegen eine flamme
diese filme schöner weil ich habe eben
scheint die haben von klopapier bitte
trocken dieser frauen alles also die
nudeln gibt es auf jeden fall später
noch heute wenn man schon ein bisschen
später also es wird langsam dunkel und
ich bin gern fußball gucken
ich habe mir gedacht wir probieren
einfach mal hier diesen riegel dann habe
ich mir gekauft für einen euro manchmal
richtig bio also geschäft hat mich noch
gar nicht von den ganzen sachen nicht
vergessen habe überzeugt weil aber das
was wir da nicht auch das frische waren
wir katastrophe außer der joghurt ja das
besagte auch lecker musst du dich mit
blauer mit blauer schminke oder mit
liedern schminke jetzt bin ich auf jeden
fall gespannt
wir machen jetzt hier 200 gramm von den
liedern angel rote beete
das ding ist ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
letzte video hiervon gesehen habt da
ging es nämlich um nur rote produkte da
war ich ja auch schon so eine art rote
beete rudel machen die sollte allerdings
rot werden
da muss man nicht verstehen dass auf
jeden fall lila und jetzt kommen wir nur
wie das geht
lutein frei vegan heute zwei spiele
irgendwie im falschen modus jetzt ist
der videomodus wieder aktiviert also die
richter auf jeden fall schon mal sehr
sehr gesund
so deute nudeln sind drin schimmern
extrem lila kann man ja sehen ich bin
wirklich mal sehr gespannt wie die
schmecken werden wir sehen uns gleich
also man muss sagen es ist auf jeden
fall wieder und die riechen jetzt auch
wir ganz normal nudeln deswegen werde
ich jetzt mal extrem gespannt ich habe
keine so oder so weil jetzt zeit nicht
wir gehen wir kunst rüber zum fisch und
ja also das sind hier die nudeln das
hier ist noch mal ein getränk was ich ja
eben noch im supermarkt geholt hat
beziehungsweise in diesem biomarkt soll
auf jeden fall extrem gesund sein ich
habe das vorher noch nie getrunken
ich hab das auch mal ein bisschen mit
wasser verdünnt ja dass hier sind die
nudeln auch wir jetzt aufregen ich bin
mal gespannt ich hoffe jetzt wirklich
mal die enttäuschen mich nicht so wie
der rest des tages ist schon getan hat
also entsteht auf jeden fall fest ich
brauche so sie dafür oder käse oder du
wirst das ding ist man kann dir auf
jeden fall essen nur die konsistenz ist
ganz anders als bei normalen leute ich
habe einfach mal ein bisschen bolognese
soße drauf gemacht und da mitspielt ist
auf jeden fall schon deutlich besser man
schmeckt das nun wirklich sehr gesund
sind aber das ist auf jeden fall pflicht
sollte was geht ab ja ist jetzt schon
der nächste tag und zwar sind wir heute
den skiurlaub gefahren kann ich euch ja
mal kurz zeigen
also wird so langsam auch schon dunkel
ich freue mich schon morgen nach oben zu
fahren
naja diese kamera zoomt extrem schnell
dran war nicht so schnell
heute ist aufgefallen war kein ende
gemacht und das war es auf jeden fall
vom video schreibt eure lieblings farbe
in die kommentare ich muss sagen jetzt
wo das video fertig ist ist eigentlich
ganz cool geworden ich dachte am anfang
so wie heißen sie wieder extrem
chaotisch aber ich habe es eine besser
hingekriegt
sonst würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
morgen 1 nur da gibt es das video der
schlechteste dönerladen aus meiner stadt
seid gespannt folgten instagram da ist
die alex ii und das war's haut rein